معنى الان من برلين سفير دونتر مولاك
الدبلوماسيه السابق ومدير المعهد الالماني
للدراسات الشرقيه اهلا وسهلا بك اذا الكشف
الان عن ان هناك سياسيه من حزب البديل هي
من
عضو سابقه في البستان وايضا الامير هنرش
او ما يعرف بالامير الثالث
هل لهذا دلاله خاصه ما الذي يطفيه على
المجريات حتى الان التي نعرفها
السيده
السابقه
هي عضو سابق في البرلمان
وحتى في هذا الحزب اليمني هناك هناك
لا يعترفون بالجمهوريه الفيدراليه
الالمانيه وهم يريدون القيام
بالحكومه ووقف البستان او البرلمان اذا في
هذا الاعتقال ل 25 شخصا هو مهم جدا هذا
الامير السابق عائلته وقالت انه
مجنون وهو ليس عضوا من العائله
نقل جنتي
فيها اذا نعم لدينا هؤلاء الناس في
المانيا
ولحسن الحظ تم اعتقالهم الان في عمليه
كبيره بدات صباح هذا اليوم وهو
في الجنوب الغربيه
وفي برلين ايضا
عباره عن 84
مليون شخص
همم
هذه المجموعه تعتبروا صغيره وليست بتلك
الاهميه او التهديد المباشر لالمانيا هناك
ايضا جنود سابقون هم عضو في هذا الاتحاد
وهم خطرون ويعرفون كيفيه التعامل مع
السلاح ويقال انهم يقدمون التدريب لافراد
في هذه المجموعات ايضا من الجيد بان
الشرطه قامت بالاستجابه واعتقال هؤلاء
الناس لكي نضمن انه في المستقبل لن يكون
هناك قوه لهم هذا يذكرنا بالناس الذين
حاولوا مداهمه مبنى الكونجرس في الولايات
المتحده بامر من ترامب اذا نحن قمنا
بالتحرك
فورا
تهديد الان لا على البرلمان ولا على
الحكومه يعني انت تشير الى ان هذه
المجموعه بهذه الاعداء وبالنظر الى يعني
كما اشرت عدد المواطنين الالمان ليسوا
بهذا العدد الكبير ولن يحدثوا تاثيرا
كبيرا في في المانيا لكن ماذا عن هذا
المجلس المركزي الهيئه المركزيه للحركه
والتخطيط
للتواجد داخل المقاطعات والبلديات وتعملته
وجهت لهم باسقاط بمحاوله اسقاط الدوله هل
مثل هذه العمليه الحكوميه والاعتقالات
تنهي مثل هذه المخططات
ويل اي ثنك سوكو
لان هؤلاء ال 25 شخصا المهمين الذين تم
اعتقالهم
لذلك سوف نرى استمرارا في الاعتقالات في
الايام القادمه لافراد من هذه المجموعه
بشئونهم وهذه المجموعه
معروفه وهي قديمه في المانيا وهم يقفون
ضد التحركات التي قامت بها الحكومه
لمواجهه
وهم لا يعترفون بالجمهوريه الفيدراليه
الالمانيه
الاولى يقولون نحن اعضاء من الامبراطوريه
الالمانيه كما كانت في السابق ولكن هذا
يظهروا مدى تطرف هؤلاء الناس هو همم
اعتقد ان عددهم ربما
بالالاف من الاتباع او ربما المئات ولكن
مقارنه بعدد سكان المانيا فهي تعتبر
مجموعه صغيره
الوضع السياسي في همم اوروبا ككل وليس فقط
في المانيا وتنام تيار اليمين هو اليمين
المتطرف الى اي حد هذه الحادثه تقاس كيف
نضعها في سياق هذا هذا النمو اليمين
امين
نرى في كثير من الدول
بدون تسميتهم
فرنسا لديها
وناس ضد الهجره وهم من اقصى اليمين وهم
حتى ضد المؤسسات الديمقراطيه في بلادنا
اذا هناك مجموعات كبيره ولكن في المانيا
هؤلاء الناس لا يقرون بالدوله ولا يعترفون
بها ولا يعترفون باي اجراءات تقوم بها
الدوله حتى يرفضون احيانا ان يقبلوا ان
جواز السفر الالماني اذا فهم متطرفون نعم
ولكن يمكنني ربما بانهم ليسوا
بالخطر كما هو الحال لدى الاخرين الذين
يتغللون في الدوله اذا فهم يرفضون الدوله
بشكل كامل وامل اننا سنقوم باعتقال المزيد
منهم ولن يكون هناك همم اجراءات او
تهديدات منهم
شكرا جزيلا لك من برلين السفير جونتشر ملك
كاس الدبلوماسا السابق مدير المعهد
الالماني للدراسات الشرقيه